Michael avenatti finds himself on the
wrong side of the law Democrats and
Republicans argue over voter fraud and
the first wave of migrants hits the
American border I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show oh man a lot to get
you today karma it turns out it has a
hell of a right cross we will get into
everything
Michael avenatti related plus the I have
to tell you that the negotiations over
Amazon as the as the true story comes
out over what cities were willing to
offer Amazon it's pretty spectacular and
pretty hilarious but first let's talk
about your energy level the reality is
we live in a fast-paced multitasking
world that demands quick thinking you
want to be razor sharp and on top of
your game all the time but if drinking
coffee or energy drinks isn't doing the
trick for you
you should try Oh max Oh max cognitive
boost it's a game-changing solution that
feels peak performance by boosting
memory focus energy and all-around
crystal-clear thinking oh max is
offering my listeners 70% off a
one-month supply of cognitive boost plus
free shipping and that 60-day money-back
guarantee so if you don't like it
doesn't work out for you you have
nothing to lose go - Oh max boost calm
Shapiro today that's oh ma xbo OST calm
slash Shapiro right now for 70% of a
one-month supply of cognitive boost plus
free shipping and a 60-day money-back
guarantee they have a couple of
ingredients they call Alpha and Omega
you may have heard of omega-3s before
this formula uses high DHA which is the
omega-3 that is critical to brain health
and supports key cognitive functions it
is combined with alpha GPC which is a
key to faster neurotransmission
improving the mind-body connection go
check it out if it works for you
fantastic Oh max boost calm slash up
hero today to get 70% off one month
supply plus free shipping and that
60-day money-back guarantee that's om ax
B oo st.com slash Shapiro today get 70%
off one month supply again plus free
shipping and 60-day money-back guarantee
Oh max boost dot-com slash Shapiro Terms
& Conditions do indeed apply all right
so you all remember Michael avenatti my
Dark Horse pick for the 2020
presidential election and he's my Dark
Horse because he was the most militant
of the Democrats he was the guy who kept
talking about punching president Trump
and I've got a hit back and we got a
punch twice as hard when they go hot
when they go low then we punch back and
all this kind of stuff well it turns out
that a quote there now
allegations that he didn't just punch
back against President Trump he punched
back against a woman here are the
allegations courtesy of ktla michael
avenatti who skyrocketed to fame as a
critic of President Donald Trump and the
lawyer for porn actress stormy Daniels
was arrested on Wednesday and booked on
a felony domestic violence charge
according to the LAPD now you'll recall
that Michael avenatti is also the guy
who trotted out Julie sweat Nick too
claimed that Brett Kavanaugh had been
involved in gang rape that Brett
Kavanaugh who is now justice on the
Supreme Court had been involved in
getting girls drunk or drugged at
parties and then he had involved himself
in gang rape trains and Michael avenatti
pushed all that out there and Democrats
jumped on it because Michael avenatti is
is their friend Michael avenatti is
somebody who says mean things about
president Trump and that's our only
standard for good people now if you say
something mean about President Trump
this means inherently you're a good
person well in this case it turns out to
Michael avenatti the evidence isn't in
right the we don't know we don't know
presumption of innocence applies michael
avenatti we don't know whether he's
guilty or whether he is innocent and in
court of law
but it's kind of ironic that a guy who
suggested believe all women is now
saying well don't believe this one over
here with the black eye the alleged
victim in the case had visible injuries
according to Officer Tony M a police
spokesman avenatti slammed the
allegation is completely bogus and
fabricated immense to do harm for my
reputation in a statement released by
his law firm a Vinod he says he's
mulling a 20/20 presidential run he
posted $50,000 bail and was released
about four hours after being arrested
and on the same block where he lives in
a skyscraper apartment on Santa Monica
Boulevard in Century City police didn't
provide any details about the alleged
victim including that person's
relationship to avenatti and here is
what avenatti had to say after being
released on $50,000 bail
I have never struck a woman I never will
strike a woman I have been an advocate
for women's rights my entire career and
I'm going to continue to be an advocate
I am NOT going to be intimidated from
stopping what I am doing
believe all women except that one who I
allegedly hit don't believe her she's a
liar so this is all going very well for
Michael a Vinod
avenatti by the way is now okay he says
he'll be fully exonerated and he
suggested that he that the woman hit him
first
apparently this is this was apparently
one of the suggestions stormy Daniels
who of course is the great feminist of
our time has released a statement on the
incident saying these are serious and
obviously very troubling allegations but
right now that is all they are
allegations we should all reserve
judgment until the investigation an
investigation michael has said he
welcomes is complete and that's what I'm
going to do agree but kind of weird
coming from the same people who said
that Brett Kavanaugh should be run out
of town on a rail lose his Supreme Court
judge judgeship lose his actual life
career family on the basis of unverified
and unverifiable allocations and
allegations that are now being
investigated by the Senate Judiciary
Committee for being false probably the
Julie sweat Nick allegations which are
now under like full investigation by the
Senate apparently is according to TMZ
the alleged incident occurred Tuesday
night but there was another
confrontation police on Wednesday
between the two at an exclusive
apartment building in the Century City
area of Los Angeles law enforcement
sources say avenatti was arrested
Wednesday after a woman filed a felony
domestic violence report the TMZ folks
were told her face was swollen and
bruised with red marks on both cheeks
security apparently apparently here's
what Tim's he says we're told Wednesday
afternoon the woman was on the sidewalk
on her cell phone with sunglasses
covering her eyes sobbing and screaming
on the phone I can't believe you did
this to me I'm gonna get a restraining
order against you we're told security
brought her inside the building took her
upstairs and Michael showed up five
minutes later and ran into the building
he screamed repeatedly she hit me first
so this is that's great she hit me first
by the way is not an actual defense to
domestic violence allegations he
apparently then angrily added this is BS
this is effing BS
we're told he tried getting into the
elevator but security then denied him
access and then cops showed up and
escorted avenatti into a corner of the
apartment lobby and spoke with him for
five to ten minutes before taking him
into custody a law enforcement source
said on Tuesday that avenatti kicked
this woman out of the apartment and
that's when the alleged domestic
violence occurred and then she went back
to the apartment on Wednesday tree of
her belongings and called police to
stand by in case things got heated so
good stuff all the way around avenatti
for his part is now blending Jacob wall
so all of the storylines are colliding
the writers of season four of
Trump I will say this they really know
how to ratchet up the tension and bring
back old storylines that we've forgotten
about like Michael avenatti and Brett
Kavanaugh like we were beyond those
story lines and then the writers were
like you know what let's bring that back
let's bring that back up whoa good
callback writers so Jacob whoa right
that was a story like three weeks ago
I'm like okay not let's let see if we
can somehow intertwine these strands and
really build this thing to an epic
conclusion for the for these second or
third episode of season four of Trump
the show so Michael avenatti apparently
is now blaming Jacob wall Jacob wall
you'll recall is a big Trump supporter
who was recently implicated in
accusations that he was attempting to
falsely malign Robert Muller suggest
that Robert Muller was responsible for
some sort of rape allegations
extramarital affairs and Wool had had
created this entire fake intelligence
intelligence company apparatus that was
gonna that was gonna reveal the deep
dark truth about Robert Muller well now
avenatti is blaming Jacob Wall
so this is kind of Awesome he says on
Twitter first Muller and now me when we
are fully exonerated I'm coming for you
Jacob wool aka char fire so all of these
strands are being brought back together
once again sure fire then retreated a
report about the case with an additional
comment surefire intelligence strikes
again so that's great if it turns out
that Jacob wool is behind a false
allegation about Michael avenatti then
we get to watch the world explode again
and then Michael avenatti becomes in
front runner against who who the hell
knows but if it turns out that all this
is false and Jacob Lowell made it up
about Michael avenatti then Michael
avenatti shoots back to the top of the
heap that's how our presidential
politics go these days and that there
are a few lessons to be learned here one
you know it's great in the United States
due process in the presumption of
innocence those things are awesome and
maybe Michael avenatti and Democrats
will learn a valuable lesson here that
regardless of your political leanings
it's good that we have a system that
protects your innocence until you are
proven guilty number two what the hell
is going on maybe that's me that's what
we should learn what is going on like
that what lesson number three if a guy
ever says believe all him and he just
spends all his time shouting believe all
women I would say that a certain amount
of time those are the guys that you
should trust the least with women
because honest-to-goodness that is such
a virtue signalling position that makes
no sense in the real world that it makes
you suspicious of the person who says it
in the first place so all of this is
absolutely delightful obviously and by
delightful I mean garbage but welcome to
welcome to the world of Trump season 4
obviously this has nothing to do with
President Trump it's just that
everything is crazy ok meanwhile I have
to take in I have to make a note on the
it's kind of a tag note on this Amazon
moving to New York and Washington DC
story to Crystal City this is pretty
spectacular so New York and Virginia
collectively have offered more than two
billion dollars in tax credits rebates
and other incentives to attract Amazon
and as I mentioned when I discussed
Amazon yesterday and the day before I
said it's kind of ironic the Democrats
have suddenly realized that if you lower
taxes and allow people more freedom
without regulation then it attracts
businesses suddenly they are saying this
about Amazon so it's okay to have low
taxes for Amazon but everybody else has
to pay higher taxes I do love this so
Governor Andrew Cuomo was asked about
this because he's a Democrat and a lot
of Democrats were saying Governor Cuomo
you say corporations are bad and they
don't pay a high enough tax rate and
then you're giving all sorts of goodies
to Amazon so what's the deal Governor
Cuomo so Governor Andrew Cuomo who is in
a running gun battle with his brother
Chris Cuomo for dumbest Cuomo brother he
defended the deal
he argued that New York has to offer
incentives because of its comparatively
high taxes no you think you think maybe
your taxes are too high and that's why
you have to offer special tax breaks to
get businesses to move in I love this he
says it like that the lack of self
awareness here is just tremendous I love
it so much so here is what Governor
Cuomo said he said quote it's not a
level playing field to begin with all
things being equal if we do nothing
they're going to Texas right right
these are your policies my friend these
are the policies that are drawn and if
you're a business in New York all you
should do is now go over to de Blasio's
office and go over to Cuomo's office and
say listen we're investigating moving to
Texas how about you give us a tax break
and Homa be like well you know we're not
very competitive maybe we should give a
tax break to that company so this is
what I urge every business in the city
of New York to do go over to the offices
of
Andrew Cuomo right now and threatened to
move to Texas you know get a P o box in
Dallas or something and then go over to
blip de Blasio's office hand him a
groundhog and say to him mayor de Blasio
we're gonna leave unless you give us
some sort of tax breaks and presumably
the tax breaks will then be forthcoming
so pretty pretty great stuff from the
Democrats other great stuff from the
Democrats with regard to Amazon I do
love this so much and so there are a
bunch of cities that we're trying to
lure Amazon and BuzzFeed news have sort
of a rundown on what those cities were
offering Amazon in order to lure them
there for their for their second
headquarters I I love it so much I'm
gonna explain in just one second but
first let's talk about how you manage
your money so betterment is the smart
way to manage your money it's an
investing tool for people who refuse to
settle for average investing it's
cutting-edge technology combined with
human expertise now I'm a person who
leaves financial management to people
who are more expert than I but not
everybody can afford that sort of thing
and this is why you need betterment it's
technology designed to help you make
more from your investments unlimited
expert advice designed to help you make
smart financial decisions tax efficient
investing strategies that give you an
edge low transparent fees constant
access to information tools that allow
you to track progress toward your goals
so you can always feel like a smart
savvy investor betterment is your online
financial adviser it helps you outsmart
average sign up today get up to one year
managed for free betterment helps you
outsmart average investing of course
involves risk but Ben Shapiro and show
listeners can get to one year managed
for free right now for for information
for more information visit betterment
comm slash Shapiro
that's betterment comm / Shapiro be et
te RM ents comm slash capiro and make
sure that you have all the resources you
need right at your fingertips in terms
of reaching your financial goals it
really is a tremendous service
betterment comm / capiro and when you
let them know that we sent you by using
that slash up here you can get up to one
year managed for free go check it out
right now so it's not just that
Washington DC and New York we're using
all sorts of incentives to a Northern
Virginia we're using all sorts of
incentives to Laura Amazon some of the
other incentives that were being that
were being used to lure Amazon are
pretty spectacular according to BuzzFeed
news cold cash wasn't the only thing
local governments used to lure Amazon
they made other desperate overtures as
well including exclusive Amazon only
executor
lounge is at local airports a personal
appeal from William Shatner himself I
kid you not
very weird Oh Amazon come we need you
right here come on
yeah and relocation reimbursements for
every migrating employee and some of
these are just spectacular some of these
are so good so Boston didn't offer the
same billion dollar tax incentives as
other HQ finalists instead it hopes that
its pool of top university talent would
draw them but they committed to seventy
five million dollars in funding over ten
years to maintain home prices around the
proposed eight million square feet of
development needed for HQ and thirteen
million dollars in workforce training
grant so all these left two cities happy
to pay off big corporations to move into
town Chicago was it happy to give two
point two five billion dollars in
incentives and potentially more half of
that offered in the form of tax credits
four hundred million allocated to
infrastructure spending apparently it
was Chicago that enlisted William
Shatner to narrate its proposal video
come to Chicago yeah this is my favorite
one
okay really this is my favorite one I
love it Columbus Ohio or just we're
speaking at the Ohio State University
they created a thirteen hundred page
pitch for Amazon they offered nearly a
half billion dollars they granted Amazon
a 15-year one hundred percent property
tax abatement which means they wouldn't
have pay any property taxes they also
offered a fifteen year thirty five
percent income tax refund which is up to
fifty million dollars annually but here
is the best part this is so good city
officials vowed to create a task force
to prevent what Columbus refers to as an
unacceptable murder rate okay again
Columbus said that they would start
investigating murders to Laura Amazon to
Columbus
so before Amazon was gonna come to
Columbus the City Council in Columbus is
like you know what and the mayor is like
you know what people getting killed or
whatever you know we have an
unacceptably high whatever unacceptably
high murder rate people shooting yeah no
biggie
Amazon's coming oh you know what guys
maybe we should crack down on the murder
here maybe should cracked out on the
murder so three cheers for capitalism
finally getting democratic cities to
acknowledge that murder is bad all it
took was a little bit of capitalist
ingenuity to get Columbus to acknowledge
may have a murder problem in their own
City so well done Democrats who it turns
out when you want jobs in your city you
actually have to lower the murder rate
in your city so all of this is is pretty
wonderful okay meanwhile there's a big
argument that is broken out between
right and left over voter fraud so the
right is looking at Florida and saying
look at look at the people in Florida
look at look at the election officials
in Florida they're obviously not abiding
by the law they're obviously attempting
to do something is it voter fraud we
don't know right that they're
responsible
there's here's the responsible take on
what's happening down in Florida the law
is not being abided by this makes you
suspicious that the law is being
violated for political reasons we don't
know how many ballots have been counted
that are illegal is it gonna swing the
election we don't have evidence it's
gonna swing the election yet but should
we be suspicious sure when people break
the law I should be suspicious right
that is the responsible way to talk
about voter fraud then there's the way
the President Trump talked about voter
fraud with the Daily Caller yesterday
here's what he said about voter fraud
generally said the Republicans don't win
and that's because of potentially
illegal votes when people get in line
that have absolutely no right to vote
and they go around in circles sometimes
they go in their car they put on
different hat they put on different
shirt come in and vote again nobody
takes anything it's really a disgrace
what's going on no number one not a lot
of evidence the people are going in
voting going back out to the parking lot
putting on a different hat walking back
in and voting again most jurisdictions
do have a signature match most
jurisdictions use you have to give an
address that actually matches up with
the name that you are giving so it's not
quite you can just maybe a Tammany Hall
and like in like 1880 maybe you could do
this right maybe like if you watch the
gangs of New York maybe that's what
Trump was doing is watching gangs of new
york and then he was like ah okay
that's how voting goes this is the best
part if you buy a box of cereal you have
a voter ID they try to shame everybody
by calling them racist or calling them
something anything they can think of
when you say you aren't voter ID but
voter ID is a very important thing now I
don't know what sort of serial President
Trump is buying I don't believe you
actually have to have ID to buy cereal
that's an interesting take
hot take I mean okay I guess even voter
ID to buy cereal okay maybe the the
frosted flakes were here's I don't know
what they're frosted with but things are
things were wild over there well all of
this has driven the Democrats oh look at
Trump he's talking about voter fraud
he's undermining our elections we saw
this from Nate Silver over to 538 Nate
Silver put out a tweet saying Trump is
undermining electoral integrity
look at him talking about voter fraud
this is just what we feared that if he
lost an election he would say that it
was a stolen election as I said a few
days ago guys you have been saying since
2016 that Donald Trump won in 2016
because of the rules he owns so he can
start with that but it's not just that
right republicans martha mcsalley in
arizona there was a there's very close
election in arizona it involves a
recount she lost the recount you know
what she did she said oh I lost the
recount I guess I'll go home now I'll go
back to my slot in the House of
Representatives Republicans when they
lose elections generally in recounts
don't protest those elections it's
Democrats who are going around literally
saying not just not just implying with
voter ID in Syria but literally going
around and suggesting then when they
lose an election it is absolutely to the
voter fraud and to every major Democrat
now who wants to run for president so
sherrod Brown has the senator from Ohio
he's kind of captain rumpled you know
that's that's his shtick is that he he
walks around looking like Martin Sheen
and Wall Street I came from a Union
house and that's what I'm doing here so
sherrod Brown who wants to run for
president just won his latest race in
Ohio and he says if Stacey Abrams who is
the Democratic candidate for governor of
Georgia and who lost who's going to lose
fair and square to Brian Kemp in Georgia
if she loses it's because the election
was stolen I'm not hearing the same
whining about from from Nate silver
about the undermining of our electoral
integrity when sherrod Brown openly says
that if Stacey Abrams loses in Georgia
it was stolen if Stacey Abrams doesn't
win in Georgia they stole it it's clear
it's clear and I would say say that
publicly it's clear what they're trying
to do in Florida to the gubernatorial
candidate and to the Senate candidate
running for re-election what they tried
to do in Ohio with some success by voter
purging what they did in Georgia when
they shut down rural precincts that were
predominantly African Americans where
many people simply
have transportation to get to the poll
okay this is irresponsible and it's a
lie there was no attempt to shut down
rural precincts in Georgia there are
some malfunctions of machines in Georgia
which were pretty quickly rectified
so sherrod Brown and he speaking of the
National Action Network so this is
obviously his attempt to reach out to
the african-american base and suggest
that they are being unduly barred from
elections which is just nonsense in fact
in Georgia the black population again in
this particular election outvoted its
percentage of the of the normal
population in terms of overall electoral
percentages is my understanding and it's
not just sherrod Brown it's not just
sherrod Brown it's other mainstream
Democrats who are dropping this court
sort of crap on a regular basis now when
we get into more of that in just one
second first let's talk about how you
mail your packages so these days you can
get practically everything on demand but
if you need stamps youself to go to the
post office when the post office is open
you may have to wait in line well you
may love the post office but you know
it's easier being at home and getting
all of the wonderful services of the
post office right from your desk 24/7
when it's convenient for you you can buy
and print official US postage for any
letter any package using your own
computer and printer the mail carrier
just picks it up you click print mail
you're done could not be easier we use
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices to ensure that we can get our
mail out on time we use exact postage
and right now when you use promo code
Shapiro you get a special offer fifty
five bucks a free postage a digital
scale and a four week trial go to stamps
calm before you do anything else there's
a radio microphone at the top of the
homepage you can type in promo code
Shapiro so go there stamps comm enter
promo code Shapiro when you do you get
that special deal up to fifty five bucks
of free postage a digital scale and a
four-week trial again stamps comm enter
promo code Shapiro for that special deal
go check it out right now okay so it's
not just sherrod Brown who wants to run
for president doing this Hillary Clinton
is doing this which says to me that
maybe she wants to run for president
again honestly she is not normally when
a presidential candidate loses suddenly
they become a lot more honest and
suddenly they become a lot more honest
they tell you all the things that were
really on their mind what they really
thought about things but Hillary Clinton
is acting like she's pandering to the
radical base so I love this Hillary
Clinton who was saying before the
election if Trump loses he's going to
say it was stolen now she's saying that
Stacey Abrams would have won if it
weren't for voter suppression so
basically you have the left claiming
voter suppression there's
virtually no evidence of voter
suppression like active voter
suppression attempts to keep legally
registered people from voting across the
country there is no evidence of this all
the attempts to suggest that voter ID
represents voter suppression is absolute
nonsense again you do have ID not to buy
cereal but to to buy alcohol to buy
cigarettes we use the ID every time
every time we are I mean when I get my
name's my credit card half the time I
have to show photo ID okay the idea that
voter ID is somehow a bar to black
people voting is belied by every
statistic from 2008 and 2012 and 2018
okay and 2016 as well people vote
because they want to vote and if you
don't want to vote you don't vote but
how many people are being rejected from
the polls because a voter ID the answer
is none okay the Democrats have shown no
evidence that voter suppression has
resulted in lower black turnout for
example it was black turnout in 2012 was
wildly outside's in states like Ohio
which is why Ohio went for President
Obama on the Left they like to say voter
suppression on the right they like to
say voter fraud so the right is worried
about people illegally voting the left
is worried about legal people not being
able to vote neither of those things is
really happening at a rapid rate okay
the idea that there are lots and lots
and lots of you legal votes out there
there's not a lot of evidence to support
that there's also not a lot of evidence
to support the idea that legally
registered people are being barred from
the polls that's a bunch of nonsense sue
but you never hear the same outcry from
people in the media about Hillary
Clinton openly saying openly saying that
if a Democrat loses in Georgia the
election was stolen doesn't that
undermine electoral integrity a lot more
than Donald Trump talking about using
voter ID to buy cereal
we all know Trump says stuff but when
Democrats mainstream Democrats say that
elections have been lost due to voter
suppression that does undermine
electoral integrity Oh Stacy well she
was one of my really strong surrogates
in the campaign if she'd had a fair
election she already would have won
what nonsense if she would have had a
fair election she would've won what made
the election unfair all the Democrats
attempts to talk about voter suppression
because Brian Kemp who is the Secretary
of State in Georgia and now the future
governor of Georgia was purging the
voter rolls of people who were dead or
who had changed addresses okay that is
not voter suppression and then it was
Chuck Schumer right Chuck Schumer says
well Bill Nelson who's the the current
senator in Florida who's about to lose
his seat to Rick Scott in a fair and
square election they're having a recount
Scott's going to have a too big a margin
for Nelson to make up that's not
stopping Schumer from saying that Nelson
is going to win and that if the votes
are fairly counted Nelson will win again
the idea here is if my side loses they
cheated and whenever that's coming from
that is not good for the the fueling of
electoral integrity in the United States
believes I believe he's won a majority
of the votes and as long as they're
counted he will continue being senator
from Florida the president Trump and
Governor Scott have just lied they've
said there's fraud when their own
Republican officials in Florida have
said there's no fraud they're trying to
shut down the election because they're
afraid of the consequences if they don't
this is such crap it's such nonsense
it's not true senator Rubio has said
over and over and over people are
violating election law they are in
Florida they they the the Broward County
election officials they keep saying they
can't meet deadlines
Alex cites Walt who reports for NBC News
was down there yesterday
he was tweeting pictures of what's going
on at the election headquarters for
Broward County the answer is nothing
literally nothing so they're saying they
can't meet deadlines at the same time
they're not even attempting to comply
with deadlines okay there is nothing
wrong with saying why in the world won't
you guys just do your damn job
and count the ballots how you're
supposed to do under Florida law and we
do have laws governing this stuff that
doesn't mean that fraud is going to
overturn an election it does mean that
if you are making no attempt to comply
with the law I'm a little suspicious of
you and I have a reason to be a little
suspicious of you all of this however
ties into a broader attempt by Democrats
to drive out the black vote in 2020
that's really what this is about by
claiming that there are a bunch of white
folks who are trying to suppress black
votes this is why Democrats are doing
this is why Democrats are like Democrats
understand that the crucial factor in
more than anything else is that in heavy
urban areas and in in in areas with
heavy black turnout in 2012 folks didn't
show up for Hillary Clinton in 2016 so
what they're trying to say now is Trump
is a racist and Trump is trying to
suppress your vote so you better show up
in 2020 and vote for Democrats and maybe
that will shift Ohio back maybe it'll
shift Wisconsin back with a heavy
Milwaukee vote maybe it'll shift
Pennsylvania back with a heavy
Philadelphia vote that is the goal here
they're trying to rebuild the
intersectional coalition now president
Trump is fighting back against that in a
couple of ways one way that he's
fighting back against that is with
criminal justice reform so he has
pursued criminal justice reform in in
what I think is a pretty obvious attempt
to win support in minority communities
because the idea here is that our
criminal justice system cracks down on
minorities too heavily even though
there's not a lot of evidence of
systemic racism in the criminal justice
system it is true that the laws do hit
black folks disproportionately because
black folks are disproportionately
involved in for example marijuana
distribution crimes for example here's
President Trump talking about criminal
justice reform yesterday which he has
embraced which is really interesting
because you know five minutes ago he was
suggesting death penalty for drug
dealers here he is basically saying well
maybe we ought to just let a bunch of
people out of prison if they are in fact
engaged in drug crimes first it will
provide new incentives for low-risk
inmates to learn the skills they need to
find employment avoid old habits and
follow the law when they're released
from prison that reduced their chances
of recidivism and in other words reduce
their chances of going back to prison
second this legislation will allow
federal inmates to be placed closer to
their home communities in order to help
facilitate family visitation third the
bill includes reasonable sentencing
reforms while keeping dangerous and
violent criminals off our streets among
other changes it rolls back some of the
provisions of the Clinton crime law that
disproportionately harmed the African
American community okay so there there
are some good things about this bill
there are some things I don't like about
the bill one of the good things about
the bill is the idea of keeping people
in prisons closer to their hometown
makes a lot of sense because obviously
you want people to be able to visit
some of this was driven by Jared Kushner
whose dad was in prison for a while and
he was unable to visit his father in
prison and so he's been pushing very
hard for this some other parts of the
bill you know as far as reducing federal
mandatory minimums for example on
certain crimes that's a lot more
unpopular among members of the
Republican base but there's no question
Trump is trying to reach out to minority
communities with this I mean that's why
even in that shot of Trump right there
where he's talking you can see in the
background there a lot of brown and
black faces specifically because this is
a political attempt by President Trump
to reach out to those crowds just in a
in a purely boiled-down political manner
in a second I want to talk a little bit
more about criminal justice reform and
then I want to talk about what Democrats
are doing to try and label Trump racist
anyway first let's talk about your
second Amendment rights when the
founders crafted the Constitution the
first thing they did was make sacred the
rights of the individual to share ideas
without limitation by the government the
second thing they did was in trying to
write to allow you to protect those
rights this would be the Second
Amendment you know how strongly I
believe in those principles I'm a gun
owner and owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility building a rifle is no
different
Bravo company manufacturing BCM was
started in a garage by a marine vet more
than two decades ago to build a
professional-grade product that meets
combat standards BCM believes the same
level of protection should be provided
to every American regardless of whether
they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer manufacture
life-saving equipment they assume that
every rifle leaving their shop will be
used in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen a law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas every
components of a BCM rifle is hand
assembled and tested by Americans to a
life-saving standard to learn more about
bravo company manufacturing head on over
to bravo company MFG comm where you can
discover more about their product
special offers upcoming news that's
Bravo Company MFG comm and check them
out at youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA to find out more about them a
fantastic company doing fantastic work
again
founded by vets and and building the
kind of products that you need to keep
yourself safe go check them out right
now Bravo Company MFG dot-com so we have
a little bit more on criminal justice
reform and also the Democrats push in
2020 for minority votes but first we're
gonna have to go over to Daley we're
calm for $9.99 a month get the rest of
this show I'll get the rest of it Andrew
Clavin shows Andrew Clavin show live the
rest of Michael Noel's show live
when you get all of those you also get
the annual subscription for $99 here you
get this the very greatest in beverage
vessels I have used its cloaking device
we always use it on the road you left us
cheers hot or cold tumbler go check it
out right now also subscribe over at
YouTube or iTunes make sure that you
have access to our Sunday special this
week it's Stephen Harper the former
Prime Minister of Canada it's a really
interesting conversation about the
differences between libertarianism and
conservatism and how much the government
should be involved in the economy and a
lot of other really good stuff go check
that out right now we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
all right so you know the criminal
justice reform bill that President Trump
is pushing as I say some of it is good
and some of it is not so good
you know Daniel Horowitz has a good
piece about this over at conservative
review talking about the flaws in the in
the criminal justice system so he points
out that there are some criminals who
have been let out of prison in similar
situations who are who are obviously not
meant to be out of prison because there
are certain cases in which people have
pled down to crimes and the and put by
pleading down to these particular crimes
they've gotten off on more severe crimes
and this means that there are people who
have actually committed pretty severe
crime so we're going to get out of
prison based on criminal justice reform
with that said President Trump is
obviously attempting to reach out to
different communities and that's
something that's that's good politically
for him Democrats however are counting
on winning the same amount of the black
vote they did in 2012 and they're
counting on heavy black turnout this is
why you have people like Nancy Pelosi
hanging out with Al Sharpton again it is
amazing to me the Democrats aren't
allowed to hang out with Al Sharpton
with no questions asked al Sharpton is a
race hustler of the worst-possible
variety al Sharpton is an anti-semite of
the worst-possible variety Nancy Pelosi
will hang out with Al Sharpton though
and then thank him for helping to save
America thank you for helping take back
America people caught all over the place
are calling me writing on the airport's
here there thank you for saving America
I give those thanks to you thank you for
saving America Reverend Sharpton thank
you for saving America okay I mean why
we're not showing that on a loop is
beyond me Republicans should be showing
that on a loop al Sharpton is one of the
worst people in modern American politics
he has been for decades and there's a
Nancy Pelosi on the podium championing
him the intersectional Coalition is in a
rebuild mode that's why senator Kirsten
Gillibrand she says she wants to run for
president because women are called to
stop Trump so it's not just black folks
who are called to stop Trump it is women
who are called to stop Trump according
to Senator Gillibrand and I think there
are many women who will look at what
President Trump has done to this country
dividing us tearing us apart really at
the seams and destroying the line
between what's right and what's wrong
I think women will feel called to this
moment as to whether they need to run
whether they need to share their vision
power Gordon is it okay so that's
her routine elizabeth warren doing the
same routine she says trump divides us
with racism again it's Democrats over
and over and over her accusing president
Trump of being divisive even at a time
when he's pretty much attempting to
reach across boundaries with things like
criminal justice reform
here's Elizabeth Warren saying Trump is
dividing us with racism not me not I it
is not I at the National Action Network
again with Al Sharpton trying to divide
us based on race no it's it's President
Trump who's trying to do all of that
Donald Trump still practices the dark
art of ruling by fear fear designed to
pit Americans against Americans you know
we have seen this road show before it is
the old divide and conquer strategy hate
and racism have divided America for a
very long time
okay the divide and conquer strategy
that's actually being employed is being
employed by and played by everyone but
it's being employed more by the leftist
mainstream tactic than the right now
I've criticized the reactionary right
when I think they're engaging in
identity politics I don't like that sort
of thing but the Democrats have made it
a main part of their platform and they
are making it even more of a main part
of their platform this is where
Democrats could be making a mistake
really electorally speaking Democrats
did well with suburbia this year because
they seemed less threatening than
president Trump but if they continue
with this routine this intersectional
coalition routine this identity politics
routine black people you should hate
Trump because he's a racist women you
should hate Trump because he's a sexist
and Hispanics you should hate Trump
because he's a racist you do this too
often
and then he suggests that all of from
supporters are racist and there is in
fact blowback
so in sherrod Brown whose main appeal in
in Ohio is that he is considered a
blue-collar moderate reaching out to
rural whites when he says that he's
running for president to stop President
Trump's hate speech giving license to
racist violence I'm not sure how he
thinks that's actually gonna help him
win states like Ohio I mean a lot of my
colleagues have thought about wanting to
be President for a long time and I
really haven't until this election mean
people have asked me I thought a little
bit about it because I'm like you are
Chris I'm worried about my country I'm
worried about longtime young federal
judges that he puts in the bench I'm
worried long-term about climate change
I'm worried about the the hate speech
coming out of the White House and that's
given licensed for people to engage in
racist or worse racist rhetoric or worse
or anti-semitic rhetoric or worse okay
they're doubling down on stupid all they
have to do is run against President
Trump on the basis that they are more
moderate than President Trump that he's
too extreme instead they're running on
the basis the President Trump is a
racist sexist bigoted homophobe all of
his followers are racist sexist bigoted
homophobes this is not the way you're
gonna win back Pennsylvania Michigan or
Ohio and yet this is exactly what
Democrats are doing on a routine basis
right now which is which is really dumb
again all Democrats have to do is say
the president Trump overstates his case
there are serious problems in the
country and we have to deal with them
rationally the president Trump is not a
rational person like I don't want to
give Democrats electoral advice because
I would prefer them to lose but the
campaign that they're running right now
is bad for the country the campaign that
suggests that everybody has to be broken
down by race and class in separate
groups to oppose President Trump it's
it's pretty ugly ugly stuff he meanwhile
the news is that hundreds of migrants in
the caravan traveling from Central
America I've been a gun arriving in the
northern Mexico border city of Tijuana
setting up a potential confrontation
with American authorities we can give
you the update on that in just a second
so the migrants are arriving in this
Caravan they've arrived in Tijuana and
it marks the end of one struggle
according to the New York Times and
making it safely across the US border
it's signaled the start of another to
get across that border something
President Trump has promised to impede
even for those seeking asylum a few of
the migrants were trying to figure out
how to get appointments with American
border officials to present their case
for sanctuary but many of them were
trying to figure out what to do now were
they going to try and seek sanctuary
trying to cross illegally or remain in
Mexico there's video of some of these
folks trying to hop the fence from
Tijuana into the San Diego area here is
what that looked like
there's a bunch of people who have like
climbed up the fence they're sort of
sitting on top of the fence apparently
these folks jump the fence and then the
sub Border Patrol and they sort of just
humming out near the fence then climb
back over so the the notion that they
just kind of fled into the the
unprotected wilds of the United States
is not actually true however when
President Trump said there are people
who are trying to illegally enter the
country in this Caravan obviously that
was true now is it a crisis that
requires thousands of troops on the
southern border I don't think so
but by the same token the notion that
these folks are just coming here to
abide by the law there's not a lot of
evidence of that either some of them are
and some of them aren't authorities in
Tijuana said they expected between 1,500
and 2,000 migrants associated with the
caravan to arrive by the end of the day
on Thursday with many hundreds more
showing up throughout the rest of the
week that influx could possibly
overwhelm the city's resources another
2,400 migrants associated with two other
separate caravans or in Mexico City on
Wednesday according to the presidents of
that city's Human Rights Commission and
they are staying in a vast temporary
shelter set up in a sports stadium you
do have to ask why it is that the
Mexican government is helping to bring
these folks to the American border like
if the Mexican government wants to help
these folks out it could just give them
residency it's not going to do that
they're obviously moving folks to
America's southern border and that is
not the mark of a government that wants
to work smoothly with that of the United
States now President Trump is right to
be worried about illegal immigration and
he's not wrong to suggest that we have
to vet the people coming in across the
southern border however they are not a
critical threat to America's national
security because we do have people at
the southern border right now and also
when Democrats deny that illegal
immigration is a problem they're wrong -
right that also is not accurate
meanwhile there's a lot of news about
the Muller probe apparently according to
The Wall Street Journal today special
counsel robert Muller's office is now
exploring whether a longtime trump
adviser Roger stone tried to intimidate
and discredit a witness who is
contradicting mr. stones version of
events about his contacts with WikiLeaks
so as you'll recall the Muller
investigation is trying to look into the
idea that Trump campaign associates were
working with the Russians specifically
WikiLeaks which is a Russian backed
front group to release information about
Hillary Clinton in advance of the
election in order to harm her in grand
jury sessions and interviews
prosecutors have repeatedly asked about
emails text messages and online posts
involving Roger stone and his former
friend Randy credit go former New York
radio personality stone has asserted
that credit coal is his back channel to
WikiLeaks a controversial transparency
group which credit Co denies their
apparently looking at text between the
two of them suggesting that critical had
access in advance to the situation with
WikiLeaks and that he was passing that
along to Roger stone then the idea would
be that stone was coordinating with the
Trump campaigns you have to connect a
lot of dots to get to President Trump
here mr. Mellors team is examining
whether stone along with several other
pro activists knew in advance
about WikiLeaks release of Democrat
emails in the 2016 campaign according to
people familiar with the matter and then
the question becomes who is Roger stone
talking to on the other end with regard
to the Trump campaign President Trump is
obviously agitated about all of this he
was tweeting out earlier today about how
angry he is at the Muller at the Muller
report and the fact is that you know I
don't know how worried he should be at
this point I think that it's a long
stretch for him to be implicated in any
of this we're gonna have to wait for the
report to come out in the end anyway
here is what President Trump was
tweeting out a little bit earlier today
said the inner workings of the Mulla
investigation are a total mess they've
heard no collusion and have gone
absolutely nuts they're screaming and
shouting at people horribly threatening
them to come up with answers they want
their disgrace to our nation and don't
care how many lies they ruin these are
angry paper including the highly
conflicted by Muller who worked for
Obama for eight years
fact-check he worked for Obama for four
years he worked for President Bush for
eight years they won't even look at all
of the other bad acts and crimes on the
other side a total witch hunt like no
other in American history and then he
talks about bomb all are protecting
crooked Hillary and Comey and mccabe and
lisa page and her lover peter asked that
be a peter struck and all his friends on
the other side the only collusion is
democrats with russia and many others
now listen i think there's a case to be
made that hillary clinton should be
should be investigated her campaign
should be investigated for ties to the
for ties including the fusion gps tied
to the russian collusion dossier and all
the rest of it but we're gonna have to
wait to see what comes out in this
report before we can actually make a
judgement i'm not going to prejudge
evidence that has not actually that has
not actually been released at this point
okay time for some things i like and
then some things that I hate so things I
like as you know
I'm a big baseball fan I've been getting
into a book by Joe Torre or really about
Joe Torre called the Yankee years
written with Tom Verducci and it's it's
really a fun read it's all about Joe
Tory's tenure as manager of the Yankees
beginning in 1996 and stretching for
more than a decade and how he had to
deal with Steinbrenner and how he had to
deal with his own team yeah again if
you're into baseball and and you like
baseball books and this is a good book
for you the Yankee years by Joe Torre
and Tom Verducci go check it out right
now it's a lot of fun you know one more
thing that I like that I forgot we are
going to be recognized by the national
radio Hall of Fame today as the
up-and-comer was as one to watch they're
giving us an award so we thank them for
that that's very kind of them that's a
that's a that's a fun thing so I will
have a trophy for the first time since I
want a spelling bee back in third grade
I guess if there's a trophy that comes
along with this which I hope there is I
mean come on what fun is an award if
there's no trophy so that that's pretty
cool the National Radio Hall of Fame
pointing out the obvious there which is
that we are ones to watch so that's kind
of fun okay back to things that I hate
real fast so I do love Bill DeBlasio so
Bill DeBlasio who just offered the store
I mean really the store to Amazon I said
well if Amazon comes here they have to
understand that they live by our values
you mean the Communist values that you
waive when you gave them a bunch of tax
breaks to bring them to Queens those
values here's Mayor Bill DeBlasio an
idiot and misunderstood if you're gonna
come to New York City you have to live
with our values and in the end what
we're going to see is not only a vast
number drops it's by far the biggest
number of new jobs this city's ever seen
I mean I don't even know that means
there to live by our values like what is
that what what does that even mean they
have to live by our values like what
they think that Amazon was gonna come in
and start rounding up all the gay users
or something like what what exactly are
they trying to is de Blasio trying to
apply what he's really trying to do is
cover his own ass because the reality is
that he like all other Democrats is
willing to offer the store to a business
that can help prop up his failing regime
in New York I mean it's really that
simple
hey meanwhile one other thing that I
don't like so president Trump did an
interview with The Daily Caller and in
that interview he went after an T fo now
I am no friend of Aunt Eva because aunt
Eva legitimately targets me and and
they've been doing so for quite a while
right they did so at Berkeley they did
so at Ohio State University the other
night
well President Trump talks about entia
and here's what he said he said these
people like the antifa they better hope
the opposition tanti that decides not to
mobilize because if they do and much
tougher much stronger potentially much
more violent and antifa is going to be
in big trouble but so far they haven't
done that and that's a good thing okay
the reason that that's not good is
because you actually do not want groups
mobilizing in the civilian area in
opposition to an Tifa to pursue violence
against other people this is why the
government has a monopoly on legitimate
use of force except in self-defense you
actually don't want you know like we've
seen brawls between antifa
and other groups in portland we've seen
it in berkeley what would be better is
if law enforcement were to do its job
and then President Trump talked about
how it was law enforcement that was
going to oppose an antifa but the law
enforcement was getting very angry
well again law enforcement sanger should
not be the standard in law enforcement
is there to enforce the law none of this
is particularly but none of it takes
down the temperature at all even though
again I hate antia and I think President
Trump speaking out against an Tifa is is
really a worthwhile thing and a little
bit of measured language here would be
useful if we want to take down the
temperature a little bit okay well we
will be back here tomorrow we will have
the mailbag so send in all of your
questions become a subscriber so I will
answer them for you and check that out
right now over at Daily wire comm we'll
be back here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah of era the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018